A lot of what we see on the big screen is
created with computers and green screens,
but some scenes are still filmed in real places
— and occasionally, once the movie is done
filming, those sets are just left behind to
be reclaimed by nature.
Here are some eerie abandoned movie sets you
didn't know still exist.
Big Fish
Daniel Wallace's novel Big Fish is set in
the fictional Alabama town of Spectre.
When Tim Burton adapted the movie for the
screen in 2003, crews built a real Spectre,
complete with a church, storefronts, and houses.
And it's all still there, minus a few buildings
that are collapsing or have burned down.
Fans of Big Fish can still visit Spectre,
which is housed on a private island outside
of Montgomery, Alabama, by paying a $3 toll.
That's one big fish for a pretty small fee...babum
chshh.
The Fugitive
A standout scene from this 1993 Oscar-nominated
Harrison Ford thriller takes place when a
prison bus collides with a train.
Richard Kimble escapes the wreckage to become...well,
you know..
"The Fugitive"
Anyway, that crash wasn't CGI — the crew
really did slam a train on a disused portion
of the Great Smoky Mountain Railroad in North
Carolina.
It cost $1.5 million to stage, and they only
had one take to get it right.
Rather than clean it up, The Fugitive crew
just left the train and bus debris behind,
where it's rusted over time.
It's quite visible on many train excursions
in the area.
Not only that, it's probably the only place
you should have this conversation:
"I didn't kill my wife!"
"I don't care!"
Star Wars
Some of the most recognizable set pieces from
the first Star Wars movies still stand, 40
years after filming started.
Standing in for Luke Skywalker's desert home
planet of Tatooine were the deserts of Tunisia,
and on that terrain sit many instantly recognizable
Star Wars buildings, including Luke Skywalker's
house, parts of Mos Espa, and a bunch of other
buildings that blend in nicely with the desert.
Just watch out for all the sand...
"I don't like sand."
Gone Girl
One of the creepier scenes in Gone Girl shows
police visiting an abandoned Missouri mall
that has been taken over by criminals and
transients.
The real mall used in Gone Girl, though, is
actually the former Hawthorne Plaza Mall in
the Los Angeles suburb of Hawthorne.
Since shutting down in the '90s, the mall
has been used quite a few times in big-budget
Hollywood movies, including Minority Report
and Evolution.
And yes that's how you pronounce it in England.
Remember Evolution?
If you don't, please enjoy this representative
sample:
"Ca-caw?
Ca-caawww.
Ha ha hee hee tooki tooki tooki tooki ca-caw
ca-ca-caw ca-caw!"
The Hunger Games
About a century ago, Henry River Mill Village
in North Carolina was a textile hub.
But when those jobs started to fade away,
it turned into a ghost town.
That made it an ideal shooting location for
the economically depressed District 12 in
The Hunger Games movies.
Being featured in one of the most popular
film series of all time has injected new interest
and cash into Henry River Mill Village.
Now, Hunger Games fans can go there and take
a tour of Katniss Everdeen's home town.
Just make sure you get there before it's too
late...
"There is no District 12.
It's all gone."
Iron Man
In the crucial opening scenes of the first
Marvel Cinematic Universe entry, Tony Stark
is captured in Afghanistan, and imprisoned
in a desert cave by a terrorist cell.
The real-life cave where this sequence was
shot isn't actually in Afghanistan, though.
Instead, the crews made their way to an abandoned
mineshaft in Cerro Gordo Mines in California.
Pretty cool that it wouldn't take much to
visit the set where Marvel Movie History was
born…
"I am Iron Man."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
movie set you'd like to visit...